I'm sure that we can all be United in
saving people from the cages of Russian
prisons unfortunately and there are some
in the world and here among you who turn
a blind eye to those cages and illegal
annexations and I'm here so that
everyone can take an honest look no
matter how hard the Russians try to
influence
there must still be Independence and I
want to thank Saudi Arabia I want to
thank the majority of you for supporting
Forum International positions and the
U.N Charter dear participants your
people have already seen that ukrainians
are people of peace and I'm also sure
all your Nations will understand the
main call I want to live here in jira a
noble call to all of you to help protect
our people